this is boss the car that won the DARPA
challenge of 2007 for self-driving
vehicles the vehicle uses GPS and laces
and radar to figure out where it is in
the world and look out and see where the
other cars are and how to drive safely
around them the big silver box over here
is the cars brain and each it's a
compact PCI chassis each of these is a
Core 2 Duo so there's about ten of them
in here and they're running a bun to
6:06 Linux up here we have our hard
drives where we can store all the
telemetry everything boss saw and
thought so if it makes a mistake and go
back and look at why that happened and
it's about a terabyte of storage there
we have a monitoring keyboard so we can
debug things on the left here we have
our GPS and a planning system which use
which uses GPS data and an inertial
measurement to figure out where the
vehicle is some safety hardware flux
capacitor and power system GPS is fairly
you know it's not down to the centimeter
really how does it avoid running over
like my dog say well so you know the GPS
wouldn't tell you where your dog is so
it uses the lasers to look out and see
where where your dog isn't tries to
avoid it and then we use lasers on the
back of the vehicle to look down and see
where the lane markings are so as it's
driving along it can detect those kind
of scent herself a register itself to
the road so how long was this in
development is a very complicated
endeavor ode imagine the actual urban
challenged this vehicle we started
working on about a year and a half ago
so we had about a year of year in a
little bit before the race so the
challenge was a sixty mile race in a
suburban environment the vehicle had to
be able to drive among other traffic so
on on challenge day there was a ten
other vehicles out there within 50 human
driven vehicles it had to stop at stop
signs it had to yield for traffic had to
be able to park and it had to be able to
do it all completely that's honestly
that means without remote control
without somebody in it it making all its
own decisions so how long until I can
just kick back on the highway and let
you know my own version of boss just do
the driving what do you think 10 years
20 years how far away is that
think kind of from a technological point
of view it's about a decade out so maybe
by 2020 you'd be able to buy a car that
has these features you know maybe a
subset of what boss can do and get you
between one place and another without
you having to worry about it